what people have been requesting
fireworks videos for quite a long time
we thought we'd add something extra into
fireworks videos we got a big old rocket
in it we filmed fireworks in the past
and it's not very exciting because it's
very smoky and you can't really see
what's going on so we figured pull up
one in a little bucket of paint and
let's have a firework II paint II
explosion it should be good might be fun
to clean up though it would be fun
thankfully I don't live here so we'll
see what happens at the end of the shoot
this is the worse shot out in it yeah it
did yes trap made a bit of a mess of the
paint so let's pour this bad stuff into
a painting
well oh it looks like bloody stinks
was it smell so bad Oh usually like this
my paint with those howling Oh dad
the paint look quite solid as it was
moving around in it yeah and the flames
just coming out of it and I like the bit
where the pressure of the smoke inside
just sort of busted out us yeah hey
there's like a volcano of paint just
full of smoke all right let's let's do
it let's do globby red and blue I think
yeah on out of that I'll get blue all
right sweet Russ smells bad right yeah
he's gonna be interested oh that's cool
oh my god
landed behind me
oh look at that that it's like that's
all eyes eyes look at it's a gunpowder
and let me make some green all right
Bangor Oh
all right well I guess when in doubt you
got the fireworks away and use a banger
that was super effective look at this
it's flushed paint into the bathroom you
guys it's got payment in September
so what's it done to our painting got a
big mess now cuz it's blown the side
completely out of our pot that we were
using oh god just look nice though isn't
it I think I'm gonna decorate my room ah
yeah it's gonna paint it white and then
do this in the middle room we've
analyzed the splash damage new species
of plant I think I prefer actually nice
that was really good like pretty die
just going up there this killer is up
there in the tree that's a good
aftermath all right what's happening now
Daniel oh I think I do anything to the
paint will just shake I just like yeah
whatever off go over in the field
oh good
that's good foot yeah I mean again so
we're going to put the kit away but
there's paint everywhere and I'm not
looking forward to clean it up
which probably revisit this one name it
with bigger tins of pain and bigger
explosives but that was definitely the
best one with it I agree
sorry bangers would be good yes sir I
set out